secret stash of 35 in broad street
will be closing her doors forever
only to reopen at 65 broad street for
one block
down still in red bank new jersey yeah
we're building a new big stack
rudy o'donnell is building it as we
speak i mean i've seen the video it
looks amazing so
we're going to a bigger space
[Applause]
what's up everybody back again with
another episode of project stash
today we got a lot of framing work done
in the last couple days i want to give
you a little bit of an update
this frame that we got all here this is
what you saw
on the show comic book man this is where
the original stash
glass from mama street kevin's first
store
that's going right here in the back of
the counter so we slide down here a
little bit
as you can see we've already constructed
what is going to be what i talked about
in the first episode
the blood mobile and the buddy christ
so up top here the blunt mobile will be
up there crashing through the ceiling
it's going to be
really cool with some neon lights and
stuff like that kind of similar
to what we got in the original stash but
a little bit more badass
the cool thing we got going here is the
shrine
of mr buddy chrysler and then when all
you great guys come in
take your photos a buddy you can
actually
pray pray to the man himself
have a little seat in our pew over here
it should be pretty badass then over
here we got my boy wayne
hooking up a real cool surprise we're
gonna do so breaking through the wall
right there
is gonna be the
it's gonna be really really cool there
that was kev's idea
got that yesterday from him so we're
gonna work on that and then right now
i'm framing it up but a quick stop sign
the facade of the original quick stop
store is gonna go here
this whole wall right here it's gonna
look like that
you guys can take some great photos
there things are moving along pretty
good
so you guys come back for another
episode in a couple weeks
peace
[Music]
you